[Music]
hey river babes
I'm your host Liana Galera and this is
your Sweetwater secrets after-show for
episode 402 chapter 59 Fast Times at
Ridgemont High
actually Riverdale high now this is our
first full episode of Sweetwater of the
season and to celebrate I'm bringing you
an exclusive interview with the core for
talking all about those infamous Spring
Break flash-forwards
we will also of course be discussing
your top hisses and kisses of the night
so get your claws out but first let's go
over the biggest highlights of the
episode with the blue and gold breakdown
all right so when we picked up in this
episode it's a little bit of a time jump
in Riverdale and although the pain is
still there Archie is focusing on his
friends so with the first day of senior
year he decided to include Mad Dog aka
Monroe what's the Bulldogs at Riverdale
high but along the way he ended up
helping Reggie through a very tough time
at home now I thought this was such an
incredible storyline for us to be able
to see Archie guide Reggie through this
problem that he's been having with a
whole life with his dad I thought it was
absolutely sensational when they crashed
the car together it was just amazing so
you know what
kudos to Riverdale for bringing such an
intense storyline and doing it in such a
great way so I loved them next up Betty
and Charles aka the half brother she
shares with her boyfriend because yup
have been working together all summer to
try and get Alice safely out of Edgar's
clutches so they enlisted the help of
the Farms black sheep Kevin to try and
get more info now I don't know about you
guys but I had no idea actually what was
going on with this whole back and forth
investigation thing I also don't fully
trust Charles and that could be because
I've been betrayed by chicks before but
you know what I don't really trust him I
don't know what's going on I don't know
why Kevin is still connected but all I
know is love Kevin as for Veronica well
she was dealing with the fact that
apparently River Doh has at EMV level
press problem and that someone leaks the
fact that she framed her father and
someone was Hiram Lodge because of
course it was truly if we're going to be
doing another whole season of Veronica
versus Hyrum just tell me right now so
that I can kind of tap out I love the
lodges that if you have another bit of
this I'm gonna explode I don't know
about you guys tell me in the comments
now last up it may have been the first
week of senior year but for Jughead he's
saying goodbye to Riverdale high for
good because he was recruited by
Stonewall prep which is basically that
school with all the Warblers from Glee
except for instead of singing they have
students who look like they're 35 that
main preppy guy who gave Forsythe his
tour around the school ya know take it
or leave it but daddy was a sweetheart
and then told Jughead you know what this
is the best choice for you you clearly
want to go to the super preppy school
all the fans are flying off we love them
so much but the fact that Jughead is
going to get another school anyone else
feeling Riverdale go jogging but the
episode ended with another flash forward
to spring break and Jughead is still
missing so to get the scoop on these
time jumps
I asked Cole KJ Lilly and cami to weigh
in now in fact I asked everyone if they
really think
Riverdale would kill off Jughead
I'm worried about you man trouble again
could they actually kill off Jughead
they could do whatever they want
I mean Riverdale is a very very shocking
place all I'm gonna say is giving you
too much is that so much
would they kill off Jughead yeah uh-huh
if it seemed like the best thing to do
what day wait what the whole season for
mystery is based off of this thing that
happens at the end of season three wash
forward and that's all I can really say
but yes the mystery of season four has a
lot to do with that flash forward flash
forwards are all the rage this view
apparently 100% it pretty much unfolds
as the season goes on we were kind of
left in the dark a little bit about how
it was gonna end up we deal with a whole
lot of different things it's not just
that one moment that way exploring I
mean obviously you Dan there are
multiple flash forwards that kind of
reveal a little bit more each time but
all I can really say is that it is sort
of building up to the main mystery of
this season or at least the first half
of the season mm-hmm so it's like a
puzzle then you just keep getting little
pieces here and there isn't it crazy in
just nine months life as we know it will
be
would they really kill off Jughead my
money run no but hit the comments right
now and tell me as we move into all
romantic moments of the night with seven
seconds in heaven we haven't done this
in a while now I don't know about you
guys but the night before my senior year
of high school I was not having hot sex
with my photoshopped looking boyfriend
in an unsupervised mansion while my best
friend was doing the same thing in the
next room but that's exactly what our
core for was doing and guys are we just
declaring that this is the oddest hookup
montage that we've had on Riverdale let
alone on the CW like things went off the
rails and pretty sure we had a Ross yeah
like whoa this was a little bit much for
me and then of course we got to sweet
show me smooches in my opinion as always
I can always use more Shoni smooches but
I'm very curious to know if you guys
think that this episode was super hot or
a little bit too much at all but yes I
do think that we needed more Shoni how
about you well that of course leads us
into the best and worst moments of the
night with my favorite segment hisses
and kisses hmm
now after that episode I asked you river
babes on Twitter to weigh in with your
thoughts and here's what you had to say
now our first tweet is from at the real
JK 93 and they said hisses to mr. honey
Reggie's dad and Cheryl talking to Jason
Lord fix it kisses to all of the couples
in this episode mr. honey doesn't know
what he's gotten himself into by messing
with a blossom PS Cheryl's hair flips
will forever be iconic yes let's talk
about Cheryl vs. principal honey in this
episode this is a big big kiss to me
because honestly it was so nice seeing
Cheryl back in that HBIC moment oh I
don't condone littering but that scene
was amazing and that hair flip if looks
could kill or if hair could kill then
you know that Cheryl blossom would have
committed murder in that episode I'm not
sure how I feel about principal honey
and I don't condone bees in offices but
you know what you deserved it man it's
not a fan of that so hmm
we're getting a couple of great comments
coming in from you guys right now let's
see oh yes
Lea Matosevic said I hate
the new principle as well yes well you
know I think we're gonna be seeing a lot
more of principal honey si si si si said
I don't like mr. honey the headmaster of
Stonewall Prep forget his name or
Charles I think they're all up to
something I agree I do think that they
are all up to something but if you would
like to get to know principal honey a
little bit more and know about the
secrets of who's hiding well you are in
luck because next Wednesday I'm bringing
you yet another sweet water snack and
that is all about principal honey I have
the whole cast weighing in on what he's
got green and brewing down the halls of
Riverdale high and just in case you guys
are confused sweet what our snacks are
my new Wednesday little treats for you
guys I know some of you river babes are
a little bit fun so that we're not doing
our full preview episodes with our three
clues so you know what I'm giving you
little baby bite-sized episodes of sweet
water and I think that you're going to
love it especially the week of Halloween
because I had so many coming from you
including that infamous show knee
interview yes our Mads and Vanessa
interview is coming the week of October
28th along with a special trick-or-treat
montage that you guys are going to
absolutely love so stay tuned for that
let's see
kisses to Archie for standing up to
Reggie's dad that was from 1to I
completely agree as I said earlier I
think that that storyline was so
fantastic I of course did not like
seeing Reggie being put in that
situation but I think that they handled
it with grace and I really hope that
Reggie's home life is still going to be
in the or is going to now be in a much
better place because red you deserve
some boom let's see gummy bear Pizza
said no way they're going to kill
Jughead yeah
I'm torn on this one I'm torn on this
one we've been thinking about it a lot
if they do kill off Jughead but maybe
then we can still see him in flashbacks
and then see how it's all led up to that
I have no idea what's going on but I do
know that Stonewall prep is involved and
we're gonna be figuring out what on
earth that is happening I I don't know I
don't but I do know that we have a tweet
from at captain topes and she said
hisses Joo Tony still not having
backstory and only saying like two
sentences the whole episode okay
yes Tony could have had much more lines
in this episode as for her backstory you
guys know I have talked to Roberto about
this tons was gonna be getting it I want
to talk about the fact that Cheryl is
lying to Tony about having Jason locked
in her what is that an atrium a basement
of thistle house god I love that house
but the fact that they still have not
been able to talk about this yes it's
only been a couple episodes but I can't
imagine that this is going to go well
for Shoni and especially since we had
such an up-and-down season in season
three I'm not looking forward to what
this is gonna do for them as a couple
what do you guys think let me know let's
see
Andrew Valdez says riverdale giving us
the Harley Ivey look of our dreams since
the movies we'll never do it well yes
Andrew I'm assuming that you were
talking about the tweet that I had
earlier this week where we were able to
debut the first look at Cheryl and
Tony's Halloween costumes they are of
course the iconic duo of poison ivy in
Harley Quinn and they look amazing and
in our upcoming Shoni interview yes the
girls are in full costume for the entire
thing they look glorious it looks
incredible
get excited okay we have Noah Manning
saying Betty is my favorite but Jughead
is a close second so they better not
kill him off but after the game of
Thrones finale you never know at least
Riverdale has always been a little off
the rails let's not talk about that
final season game of Thrones no way
Ashley Lake Lee says kisses to bug has
amazing relationship I'm in love it was
so nice for them to have that moment
where Betty looked at him and said you
know what if we can get through this
we've gone through much worse which is
the understatement of the century
I understand that Jughead wants to be
challenged intellectually you've always
seen that he's he's brilliant I guess
but the fact that he wants to go to that
Stonewall prep which I am not a fan of
what did you guys think the guy leading
him around being rude to Betty and
making that awkward moby-dick joke like
also I thought that was the student like
let's talk about the fact that the
Riverdale kids already look too old for
being in high school like who are the
Stonewall Prep people like what is this
they all look like they're in their 30s
but yeah so we have Ashlyn Blakely
saying kisses the bug heads relationship
I'm in love oh goodness gracious you
guys Michaela Taylor says I really don't
trust any of the new characters I'm also
theorizing now that mr. honey is working
for Hiram's eye that tracks to quote
Branca that tracks but if mr. honey is
working for Hyrum then that's I feel
like is just going to be another
storyline that we've seen before
love your Riverdale but stop having the
devious people working for Hyrum well
maybe just stop with Hyrum for a little
bit I did like that we got him in small
doses but what did you guys think about
the fact that Veronica okay let's let's
keep talking about Veronica because we
have actually a tweet right now so we're
gonna go on a whole ranch yeah so we
have mijoo I'm Donna five one one said
kisses to Archie for calling out
Reggie's dad and tons of kisses to
Veronica on that all that jazz
performance I have so many thoughts this
is like a hisses kisses combo about this
performance so let's take a look the
kisses are of course to the fact that
Veronica Cheryl and Tony look incredible
and cami sounded amazing
the hisses go to the fact that she's
doing the super sexy performance in
front of a bunch of old reporters as
soon as she said like I'll talk to you
after a special performance at labahn OE
you really lost me and that's saying
something because I what like I loved
that we're getting in the music I still
of course miss Josie so it's nice to see
that Riverdale is still gonna be giving
us that musical aspect but the context
in which it was presented to us was
weird but once again
way to go cami you crushed it that was
not an easy song but so run this no
thigh so this is two Stonewall prep yeah
exactly
quite storm says question do you think
that Kevin and Charles can be trusted
yes - Kevin no - Charles and that makes
me sad because I don't want to see Betty
go down another path where she's
trusting someone although she never
fully trusted chick but honestly I feel
like history is repeating itself a
little bit right now and I'm not sure
how I feel about it
I would have also had liked to have seen
some scenes between Charles and Jughead
considering their
also siblings remember that but hmm I
guess time will tell
I do know that the next episode episode
3 is where all the farm craziness comes
to a head and we're gonna get a lot of
answers so that's gonna be really good
plus the return of Chad Michael Murray
which who else is excited for that just
me okay
next up we have a tweet from at Nancy
river drew and she said kisses to Kami's
vocals they were amazing
grumpy jellybean about jug leaving the
archie reggie friendship and jugs
pouring out his drink at the party yes I
loved that scene hisses were two jugs
tour guide they forgot that Weatherby
shut down the blue and gold in season
two and Betty's outfit here in this
picture but that kiss is definitely a
kiss I will agree I thought that was
such a sweet bug-head moment as for the
principal Weatherbee shutting down the
blue and gold honestly I feel like when
your principal runs off to go join a
cult and knowing what I do about
principal honey maybe he wants things in
order to say to the blue and gold I have
no idea but you know what that works in
my little brain
okay Tommy Daniel said bring back moose
Kevin deserves true love and happiness
well you know what that leads me to my
last and biggest kiss of the night it's
going to sweet sweet baby Kevin cuz you
know what you guys Kevin headlines
in this episode look at he's speaking
there and he's speaking there or not
right there but you know what it was so
excited to see him and Betty come back
together I do not understand exactly
what they were fighting about because I
think that the farm connection was just
still I'm ready to be done with it but I
was excited that we got more Kevin I
think we got more Kevin in that episode
than we did all of season 3 I don't know
about you guys but I'm excited for Kevin
to find love do we think that fangs is
gonna be is like end all be land
I don't think so I think that we need to
find a new ones warm but only time will
tell and you know what I think that's a
good place to end it right there on my
adoration for Kevin aka Casey now thank
you all so much for watching and be sure
to join us next week for our Sweetwater
after-show for episode 403 chapter 60
Dog Day Afternoon and of course our
Sweetwater snacks that are now gonna be
coming on Wednesdays but first you know
what to do press that subscribe button
so you never miss an episode
give this video a like and then hit the
comments or chat with me on Twitter to
tell me your kisses and kisses of the
episode how are we feeling about Cheryl
vs. principal honey which couple had the
sultry of scenes and what are your
thoughts on those flash foreheads for
forwards flash-forwards I'm just so
concerned as jug I can't even speak
right now tell me everything and I will
see you next week bye river babe
[Music]